hello everybody and welcome to today's
live broadcast morphology driven high
Plex spatial analysis of tissue micro
environments presented by dr. Matthias
Hobart and Tracy the gear and Christie
jewel of lab routes and I will be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by Leica Biosystems and nano
string for more information on our
sponsors please visit lego Biosystems
calm and nano string calm
now let's get started I would like to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them in the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top-right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by using the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and the
software is continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I would
now like to introduce today's presenters
dr. Matthias Hobart senior product
application scientist nana string and
tracy de Geer director advanced tanning
innovation like us io systems for
complete biographies on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome dr. Hobart welcome Tracy dr.
Hobart
you may now kickoff our presentation
well thanks a lot for the introduction
let me first introduce our company to
you I'm just bravely on industry was
founded in 2003 as headquarters in
Seattle and focuses on getting as much
information out of as little tissue as
possible
and in addition to research products we
have two platforms by now we also do
have an improved diagnostic test for
brands for breast cancer running on our
encounter platform the physique no test
long history of multiple gene expression
essays and in this paper emerge they
performed a gene expression analysis of
FFPE samples as a goal to identify a
signature that can predict response to
an entire pd-1 blockade they identified
an 18 gene signature that they call the
GE p but which we refer to as the tumor
information signature or the tist
signature and in the grass at the bottom
of this slide you can see comparison of
progression-free survival on the y-axis
and the tip score on the x-axis patients
with none inflamed tumors on the left of
this graph really respond to the PD one
block a treatment of the study P and
almost all of them or almost all of the
responders have inflamed tumors but that
said if you look at the quadrant at the
lower right of that graph there are so
many patients that inflamed tumors that
do not respond at all
so we already know several parameters
that can predict for respond to a
certain treatment but to be able to
increase this predicting we still need
to fill the funnel and we need to find
more candidate biomarkers the challenge
method or heterogeneous tissue is that
the biggest portion of it is using not
relevant to the disease Marie and will
simply dilute the signal that might then
reveal difference in expression levels
between two patient groups and if you
focus on if you focus your analysis on
let's say the immune microenvironment in
immune oncology research you will reveal
markers that may predict a therapeutic
response but that would otherwise be
lost when you study the whole tissue at
this M at once the spatial context is
crucial for mile-marker discovery which
is also reflected in the development of
the immuno score part of which is
determined by the cell type the sound
density and also the location of the
immune cells of is a location this
spatial context comes into playing the
current paradigm force is a trade off if
you want to run high plaques gene
expression analysis or protein
expression analysis you lose the spatial
information but on the other hand if you
do imaging analysis that is usually done
in a low plex fashion and has rather
poor quantification the given the
cellular complexity and the
ever-expanding combinations of
therapeutic strategies there is a
critical need to attain more biological
information from limiting amounts of
clinical samples
and one researcher with exactly this
problem was one of our earliest
collaborators dr. Aubrey Thompson from
the Mayo Clinic in Florida he did
receive two slides per patient out of
the Phoenix trial and treble negative
breast cancer and he wants to find new
biomarkers that predict which patients
are more likely to benefit from
capecitabine adjuvant treatment and all
of those two slides he had he decided to
use one of these precious slides per
patient on running of bollocks in
expression analysis the C breast cancer
III 60 panel from nano string and then
use the remaining slide per patient for
high plex facial protein analysis the
breast cancer 360 panel studies 770
genes in about in mouth together a
result as have another incentive genes
it also includes a lot of gene
signatures like the tumor inflammation
signature but also a lot of other gene
signatures that are analyzed at the same
time together miss a single genes on the
left of this slide you see the
clustering of the expression of what he
got out of his study using the BC 360
signatures and across the samples
showing distinct clusters across all
those annotated signatures and when you
look specifically for gene expression
changes which is shown on the right on
this slide between patients this longer
survival left in this graph on the right
and shorter survival on the right in
this graph a strong immune signatures
really is revealed in the capacity mean
cohort that is predictive of longest
survival and these immune signatures
suggest a deeper interrogation into the
immune micro environment may actually
reveal additional candidates and to do
so to look into the Indian micro
environment that Lucien's fears that
associate with this form
the geometry form was used to separate
the tumor micro-environment into a CD 45
and a CD 68 enriched reading physically
separating it from the tumor compartment
racial profiling of over 30 proteins we
will significant heterogeneity that can
then be leveraged to reveal you
candidates on the left you see cd45
enriched swimmer and on the right you
see the cd68 enriched stroma and what
you can see is that actually they do
look different meaning that you have two
different fractions in front of you and
that that was a good result from the
start
the preliminary analysis of the cd68
enriched stroma
revealed increased expression of I do
one and PDL to among other markers that
associated with a positive response
while increased expression of the
stromal protein fiber nekton was
associated with poor prognosis on the
very left of this graph and be bulky
gene expression analysis had also
revealed an association of increased PDL
to expression that's longer for long
survival which is a good concept so the
same result basically as his special
study but this out the spatial context
even more relevant marker idea one what
has been lost so wouldn't have in
reviews because it's only relevant in
these cd68 enriched reagent
but how does this system actually work
the geometry to hold facial analyzer can
detect protein and RNA and to do so it
uses either antibodies linked to small
DNA barcode or ish probes linked to a
DNA barcode that then reveals the
identity of the probe is linked to and
in both cases are the protein or RNA the
linker is cleavable by ultraviolet light
in the case of protein detection if you
stain an SSP tissue slide there's a
larger panel of these are coded
antibodies and then shining UV light on
only a small area of the tissue our bar
codes will be cleaved off in that area
and can then be picked up to quantify
the amount of barcodes or the amount of
antibodies that are bound to this
specific part of the tissue
using standard IHC methodologies tissue
sections are stained with a mixture of
recently labeled on the top and what you
see on the bottom DNA labels of our
coded antibodies so simply mix them and
then do i'm very similar to I'd see
staining them if recently labeled
antibodies are used to reveal the
morphology of the tissue that can then
be used to identify regions of interest
quantifying the larger panel of our
coded antibodies that are bound in each
of these regions of interest so the
barcode antibodies are simply invisible
and the presently labeled antibodies
other ones that you see on the slide to
select the regions you're interested in
so this slide shows you the workflow
that is applied in any typical geometry
the slide preparation protocol can be
automated using the leg up on rx
platform to minimize the steps needs to
be done manually in the nav and after
the slide prep and staining of the
slides in a fashion very similar to
normal
I'd see protocol the slides are then
inserted into the genomics platform
which can analyze four slides in
parallel the first thing the instrument
does is that it generates a 20x high
resolution scan of the slide using the
expressions in quality markers that have
been applied and directly on the skin so
on your screen you can then draw your
reasons of interest and once this is
done the instrument or shiny relied on
the first region of interest or ROI and
collect the clicked of barcodes from
this particular region of the tissue
with using a micro sim and deposit those
barcodes and a micro well played within
the instrument and then the stage moves
to the next RI CH ng relied on it looks
up the barcodes and deposits them in the
next velocity microplate and this
process is repeated until all the
records from all our eyes have been
collected and deposited in the
collection plate and after this is
finished the barcode in each well will
be quantified using normal strings
encounter system the cones are then
transferred back into the German system
which then links the counts to the RI
they have been collected from and allows
complex data analysis that's a full
software solution that is integrated
into the system
as you can see in the graph on the right
the automated slide type workflow using
the Lanka bond rx platform is highly
consistent with the manual assay and it
uses hands-on time by about four fold
and at the same time improves precision
and consistency during the sample prep
stage
but how can we make sure that you relied
only shines on the selected areas on the
tissue we use two digital micromirror
devices in the genomic system that
consists of millions of tiny mirrors and
each of these can be adjusted or will be
adjusted automatically to ensure the
light only shines on the tissue where
you selected your regions of interest
and in addition to just drawing circles
to predict these areas we can also make
use of an algorithm that can create a
mask to shine light depending on the
person's staining on your tissue and
like you see in this example in the
middle a mask can be created that
adjusts to your sample to shine light on
only where the yellow fluorescence is
and therefore only the black holes from
this example are from price up to your
tumor area will be cleaved off while in
a second step you can create another
master then we'll shine light on the
mining cells in the R I'm to represent
the expression making the tumor
microenvironment and each sample will
then end up in a separate well of the
collection plate physically separating
them from each other so it can easily
separate tumor from tumor
micro-environment for example
the reasons of interest or our eye
selection is what makes the DSP
technology powerful and versatile we can
draw other geometric shapes of your
choice on the tissue or you can use the
built-in software algorithms which I
just showed you in the previous slide
the separate tissue by different
segmentation or you can also select rare
cell types which are interspersed
throughout your RI or which is not yet
included in the software you can do a
contour field of graded patterns
this slide shows you a profile of
different geometric our eyes that have
been selected based on staining with
various lessons morphology markers and
without going into any detail on the
heat map on the lower left you see that
every three are eyes selected from a
similar area just based on the amaze us
and mythology marker on this tissue show
similar pattern on the heat map while
being completely different from our eyes
taken from other areas of the tissue
based on other florescent morphology
markers that's the same proof of
principle to get the most out of your
same we offer fully annotated panels
both protein and RNA essays to allow
maximum flexibility we design the
antibody panels in a modular way long to
choose and pick modules to add to a core
set of regions we offer about 50 flex
antibody assay for immune oncology
related questions and a about 30 flex
antibody sa trained neuroscience with
modules for other Parkinson's or
Alzheimer's research the encounter base
RNAs a on the top ride features a list
of 84 genes around immune oncology
research and all of our panels protein
and RNA allow the addition of custom
markers that can then be added to the
existing content and soon to come on the
lower right on this slide is a larger
panel of next generation sequencing
readout that will allow the profiling of
about 1,500 RNA targets
the geometry SP provides an integrated
environment so it allows a seamless flow
through the experiments in workflow from
scanning a slide and selecting the
segments of interest on the geometry and
coordinating with the encounter to
account and profile each segment to the
QC and analyzing the data as you can see
on the top right on the screen the
imaging part is coming from the goe
system the columns are coming from the
encounter system and then they're
integrated into each other to give you
the best out of your analysis if slide
shows the workflow of measuring high
Plex proteins or RNA on the gel makes
ISM with quantification then done on the
encounter system or soon to be released
next generation sequencing
a next-generation sequencing readout
allows for theoretically unlimited
flexing here you can see they early
native generated from three distinct our
eyes on the same tissue compared to a
bug and the SSA profile on the left you
can see that each of these our eyes does
generate a distinct gene expression
profile if you look closely on the right
on the right
the first larger and say for next
generation sequencing we know that we
are going to launch early next year is
based on three panels that we currently
offer for our encounter platform
choosing about 500 genes each out of our
palm cancer pathways immune profiling
and IO 360 panels and this allows us
especially study the biology of tumor
immune and micro environment with a
highly annotated essay
the representation of data of fifteen
sixteen hundred genes generated by this
assay could be represented by such a
react own map as you can see here so
each of these little trees that you see
represents a major pathway to allow an
easy visualization of what is actually
happening in the tissue in this example
you can see two invasive margins on the
bottom being analyzed and one of the
invasive margin on the right shows on
new meaning that know that the
expression is known the invasive margin
on the left has a much brighter pattern
which means that we can find a much
higher expression level there or in
other words the invasive margin on the
right is inactive while the invasive
margin on the left is active
a regardless how it's implemented the
cloud architecture of the Janik system
allows many users to interact with the
system at the same time so while only
one user can actively control the
instrument physically in the nav many
users can be aligned images selecting
regions of interest to profile or
analyzing their data simultaneously so
they can login from remote from their
desk don't have to be physically
standing in front of the instrument to
do so
to summarize the geo mcsim has numerous
advantages it can analyze multiple
analytes in the same tissue slides in a
single pass it's not that high
multiplexing capabilities and run
spatial high flex analysis on both
protein and our name the counts are
quantitative and can be analyzed in the
integrated full software package that
comes with the instrument the resolution
is very high meaning that the digital
micro mirrors can shine light on a
specific blood 1 square micrometer
region allowing two big single cells
from our eyes and as we are only
touching the tissue by light UV light
the whole process is non-destructive so
your precious tissue slides can be used
for other analysis afterwards it's
definitely not destroyed and the
throughput is high enough to run the
system in a clinical environment and
this time at the end of my presentation
I'm happy to take questions later but
now I'd like to pass on the presentation
to Tracy the gear thank you
thank you very much with us for that
kind introduction and my name is Tracy
to gear and I am the director of
innovation for like a bias system and
with that I actually get to work with
the bond rx instrument which is the
instrument that naina string needs to
develop their essay on so we're going to
talk a little bit about how an
instrument like the bond or X can be
used to do routine research or
translational research or if you're a
partner like naina string can be used to
do all of the wonderful things that
naina stream did so let's go ahead and
get started
so the barbaric instrument is actually
built around freedom to discover and
when you consider the freedom to
discover there are three things that we
talked about under freedom to discover
its explore your ideas which as
researchers that's something everyone
wants to do is to be able to explore the
way that we envision research goes so
any idea that we have in our kid we want
to be able to get out there for the
world accelerate your testing program so
to be able to do things in a timely
fashion and if you're someone like manna
stirring or another small biotech
company and you want to be able to
commercialize the things that you
discover so that you can share those
with the world so that the three pillars
that the bond direct stands on is
explore your ideas accelerate your
testing program and hopefully
commercialize what you had in your head
that you wanted to share with the world
so let's start with explore your ideas
and talk a little bit about what that
actually looks like if you're a
researcher
so when you think about exploring your
ideas I some out of the research lab and
one of the things that is the most fun
about being a researcher is to be able
to take something that you have in your
head and actually get it out there to
either publish or to show to other
people but one of the things that can
frustrate you as a researcher is that
inability to get it out of your head and
get it where you want it especially if
you're trying to build to build
something on a piece of automation and
you can't get it to do what you want it
to do so one of the things that the
instrument is is very very flexible it
lets you run third-party assays so
things like the name of string assay you
get to use the same flexible software
that's Nana string and other partners
use you also have a lot of things that
like the provides as well so there's
detection there's open detection
containers all of those provide
flexibility to the system so that
researchers themselves can try to get
within their head out onto a piece of
automation for consistency's sake
because if you want to publish it then
you want it to look the same over and
over and over again so that someone can
reproduce what you did and that is sort
of the hallmark of research so there are
lots of things and the instrument that
you can do you can do circulating tumor
cells you can do mRNA you could do micro
rna's so the instrument has a lot of
capabilities and then you have the
capabilities to sort of shape your own
research a little bit
so that's exploring your ideas now the
technology has been around for a long
time so the bond Rx has a long history
it was first introduced in 2011 and as
the instrument has grown based off what
we've heard from the customers we've
added additional flexibility
year-over-year to sort of shape that
instrument into what researchers told
they wanted it to be and we've worked
with our partners to add additional
things so that we can keep up with the
times and allow researchers to keep
innovating with us
there are a lot of possibilities for
what you can do you can multiplex you
can do probe work you can do
fluorescence it's kind of working with
your imagination a little bit and then
working with the technical support teams
and then working with the partners like
manna stirring that give you the latest
and greatest in technology
now there are a lot of customization
options that are available on the
instrument so you can do proceeding
customization you can do image and
retrieval customization staining
customization and as you look at the
procedures that were shown by test you
actually saw some of the work that they
do to customize things to fit the
procedures that they need and they
continue to work with us to add to that
customization in order to make their
procedure the best that it can be
you can also customize within the
procedure so if you needed a longer DX
or you needed to change something you
can do those pieces as well
you could customize your antigen
retrieval you can change incubation
times and temperatures so these are all
flexibility features that were added to
the instrument to give researchers in
the laboratory more flexibility but to
also give our partners flexibility to
bring new assays to you
now when you look at other things that
are available in the area of explore
your ideas you can do any marker you
want to on there so if you wanted to
bring in third-party antibodies you can
do that if you want to use antibodies
from the like a portfolio you can do
that if you want to make an antibody of
your own you can do that you can create
your own detection systems so you can
use the same type of detection that our
partners use when they use the open
detection to create something that works
for you and then there's a new feature
in the latest version of software that
gives you the ability to select your
dispense type that used to be a features
that you had to have a technical support
person come in and adjust for you it's
available right in the software now so
that you don't have to wait on us to
come to you you can actually make those
adjustments on your own nail but the
technical support people are happy to
guide you if you have
and then you have something called the
temperature toolbox now the temperature
toolbox has actually been around for
quite some time it actually lets you do
selections of temperatures within the
staining protocol but not everybody had
the temperature toolbox installed on
their instrument it's now a regular part
of the procedure so that you can choose
the temperatures that you want things to
incubate at and that makes that
flexibility all that much better
now the second pillar that we talked
about in the beginning was accelerate
your test program
and speed is not something usually
associate with the research laboratory
because unless you're a really high
throughput research laboratory we don't
rely as much on speed at least I know
the research lab that I came out of
didn't um we weren't it pushed for speed
as a hospital laboratory who had
clinical patients going through but
where speed is really important for
research laboratories is if you take an
assay that takes days and days to run
and you can actually compress that time
so if you look at something like banana
string I say that you're doing a lot of
hand steps if you do it manually and
then you have an overnight incubation
and then you actually get to go on to
the gmx CSP that actually is a lot of
hand time that you have to dedicate
someone to be with you're sloppy but if
you can actually take some of that hand
time out and dedicate that to an
instrument that frees up that person to
go on and do other important tasks in
the laboratory or to do other research
or to do analysis or things that are
very important to that laboratory that
may have to be delayed somewhere because
you've got them doing other chap so
there is speed in the laboratory for
research it's just not looked at the
same way as what you would look at it if
you are a clinical laboratory
so the instrument does give you that
speed factor in the fact that it can
take taps that would normally have to be
done manually and move those somewhere
else in some of these longer a phase
that we do as researchers
there's also efficiency in that because
if you're better allocating your staff
to do things more efficiently then you
can get your analysis done quicker you
can get your papers published a little
easier you can get all of those things
that are important to the running of a
research laboratory and the longevity as
a research laboratory and recognition
sometimes of your laboratory now the
instrument itself actually helps you be
efficient it's got the three drawers
that each worked like an independent
instrument so if you have more than one
team that is using the instrument then
the team's can actually share the
instrument a little easier because they
don't necessarily all have to be there
at the same time it's easy to remove and
add reagents is easy to start slides if
they are not all using the same trays
you've actually got the unboard bulk
reagents that you can see from across
the room when they need attention the
backlit Lebon RX helps you gauge when
things need to be added and removed for
bulk fluids so that you don't run your
boat fluids out and then the instrument
itself is not a huge instrument and
actually has a reasonable footprint that
you can actually slide into place
one of the things that happened with the
latest update as the software was a
little bit more friendly look and feel
to the front I did not start out on this
instrument I have run several different
types of instruments in my research life
but I like the look and feel of it it
was a very intuitive look and feel it's
a very easy instrument to learn as a
researcher which is always good because
you've got a million things going on in
your head at the same time you can see
the boat fluid on the instrument you can
see the drawers you can see where all of
your reagents are in the trace I like
that because I don't want to spend a lot
of time looking for things and that made
things very easy for me and when you're
doing development work like nana string
did it let them help let them keep up
with things as they were walking by
visually so that's a big plus if you're
a researcher it's also big plus if
you're someone who is a partner who is
developed doing development work
this is the bottle we were just talking
about better back when this was a new
feature when the bond rx 6.0 came out it
was something that was actually
developed by a group called back burner
out of Melbourne they actually come up
with things that aggravate customers and
then ways to solve days and this was
something that had aggravated people was
that they had trouble telling when their
fluids because all the fluids are clear
and we're running late and so someone
down there came up with the idea of
putting lights behind them and making
them more visible and then changing the
configuration of some of the bottles and
that actually has been something that
was internal innovation for people but
it was based up with Commerce and
researchers said really irritated them
and something that's important to
researchers at least I know it was
important to me is consistency and
results because if you're going to
publish you have to be able to get the
same results over and over and for
groups like nana shrink who are going to
commercialize you have to have
consistency
you can't commercialize a product that
doesn't show consistency so part of the
consistency on the instrument comes from
the cover child and that cover child
technology allows your tissue to stay
moist it also allows an even pull
through of reagents and that gives you
consistency they're also easy to take
care of and it keeps delicate tissues in
place and preserves them that allows us
to do some of the unique things you saw
in the slide that showed all the
technologies and things that people had
run things like CT sees that cover child
technology allows for that to happen
now these are some of the partners that
actually run on the bond RS so there are
partnerships with everything from CTC
companies to multiplexing companies to
the wonderful partnership that we have
with Nana strings and their multiplexing
technology and their gmx DSP
and I know that Matias took you through
this earlier but this is one of the
wonderful things about having a
partnership with the company like Nanna
string is if you look at all of the
things that go into making a slide that
goes onto the VSP happen then bond Rx is
a wonderful piece of that because it
takes away time-consuming preparation
pieces so baking see waxing add to take
retrieval enzyme free treatments all of
those pieces can be run on the
automation so that you get that
consistency piece but you also free up
people to do other things that are
important to the laboratory during that
time and then you can do your overnight
in your RNA or your protein and then
once that is done you can actually go on
to the DSP now there is a fully
automated version of the RNA coming
there being worked on right now and so
hopefully you will see that in the
not-too-distant future
and then the commercialisation peak and
this is where knee and the string is
right now with us
and that's an ideal type of balancing
act between being able to use those open
detection pieces that nana stiring uses
a custom protocol which is something
that you'll see going through the
different protocols on the instrument
the standard bulk reagents and you get
that run to run consistency and so
freedom and flexibility plus consistent
results and that gives researchers the
ability to publish it gives them the
ability to do coasters all of these
wonderful things that we as researchers
like to put out to show off the
wonderful work that we do
for some companies that have been in
this this cycle with us for a while
you've actually got the ability to be on
the bond direct to do good marketing
agreements like Nana string has done and
then we've had had partners that have
gone on to go from being on the bond
direct to actually make anything into
the clinical world on the bond three so
that's the hopes of all of our partners
and is to go that direction so
commercializing is a wonderful thing and
we love to do the CEM marketing
partnerships that we have with companies
like that string
so what we like to see is companies come
through these partnerships with us and
this is sort of a list of where our
partnerships have gone and then you get
to the end and hopefully we'll see more
of you in this pipeline
- thank you very much for your time and
your attention and I'll nail open the
floor for questions
Thank You Tracy and welcome back dr.
Hobart thank you for your presentations
and now let's start our live Q&A portion
of the webinar go to our audience if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen and click send okay let's
get started
dr. Hulbert let's start with you here's
our first question
can you customize or add in targets or
antibodies to your assays
yes thank you that's well that's a very
good question that comes up rather often
actually as we know we can design our
panels as good as we want to we will
always be missing that one target that a
particular researcher wants so we made P
sorry so we made all of our panels
customizable so the protein pedals and
the RNA panels like shown on this slide
over here can be customized you can add
in your own markers and to do so whether
we can label them with the necessary
barcodes DNA barcodes for that or while
we part it up the app cam for the
protein part you can look at the whole
IHC validated antibody portfolio and
they can actually label them directly to
the geo mcc's
well mark codes and then ship them to
you so they do the custom labeling for
you
thank you dr. Hulbert now next question
how many fluorescent markers can I use
yeah the instrument has fourth lesson
channels so basically it's a microscope
and that has fourth lesson channels one
of them we tend to use as a DNA marker
the DNA dye which is used in the fitzy
channel and that leaves us three other
options to put in morphology markets
thank you let's see our next question
we've got so many questions coming in
here we go
how do you normalize
well the the system the system has a
full data analysis software integrated
and you can use that to normalize in
multiple ways fortunately there is no
1:1 normalization fits all the software
allows you to normalize in multiple ways
you can normalize by Area arm off the RI
that you took or the segment you can
normalize by the amount of nuclei in
that regions of interest and you can
normalize by housekeeper's which are
always added to our panels and you can
always buy background subtraction so
there are the necessary ID G's in the
case of protein or negative probes for
the RNA panel are also integrated so we
have it well we kind of have it all in
there you can use it or leave it
housekeepers IgG whatever you like is
all in there and then it's up to you
what you want to use in the end
thank you dr. Hobart okay we have
another question here
Tracey this one's for you how do you add
new reagents onto the bond Rx for assays
like nano string
that's a very good question for assays
like the Nana string and that there are
open reagent containers that you can use
they can either be full containers or
they're our titration containers that
can actually be used for adding reagents
and so if you look at the half protocol
that is used by Nana stirring and that
actually has areas that they add their
own reagents into during the free steps
and so for enzymes and things like that
you can use those or you can use the
ones that like I already have in this
whole protocol that's being developed
and that actually relies on the detect
open detection containers and it also
relies on open antibody and probe
containers and if you're using very
small amounts of those the titration
containers actually are good places to
put those those items depending on the
number of slides that you're running
Thank You Tracy our next question how
can you optimize segmentation for
different cell size or different cell
shape like Lea versus lymphocytes
and that's that is actually easily done
with they suffer so the algorithm once
you select your RI and you want to do
segmentation you do so on the
fluorescent markers that you apply to
the slide that you stand you slide with
if you're using a black ideal cell
marker or a lymphocyte marker labeled in
different pressing colors the
segmentation algorithm will pick up the
colors so you can basically segment red
cells into one well well in the end and
then green cells in the other well in
the end and you can go like like that if
you want to normalize that in the end
you can either go by nuclear count then
you have the size of the cells all dealt
with or you can do housekeepers or
whatever you like but the segmentation
algorithm actually takes care of that
very nicely and can always tweak that
manually if it doesn't go to your to
your liking
dr. Hobart and Thank You JC to gear both
for your informative presentations today
and thank you for your QA I do want to
remind the audience those questions we
did not answer today and those that come
in during the on-demand period will be
answered by our speakers via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration again I would like to thank
Lavrov our sponsor and Leica Biosystems
and nano string for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand and labret swill alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event that's all for
now and we hope to see you again soon
have a great day